[Music]
Zendaya belting out Usher's confessions
at his Las Vegas residency yeah I know I
know and right next to the actress her
boot Tom Holland it's great to have that
support and that love around you yeah
check out the Spider-Man actor next to Z
in a green hoodie as she sings along to
Usher's hits
[Music]
It's a rare public outing for the couple
who mostly keep their romance out of the
spotlight
this comes after a Zendaya's brief
return to music last weekend
[Applause]
[Music]
yup she totally shocked fans with this
surprise performance crashing labyrinths
set at Coachella
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm sorry I don't know what happened I
don't know where I don't know what I
sounded like but I just was like you
know what I'm just gonna have fun
and
whatever you know and uh it was so
special
and everybody was singing along and it
was just it was so cool so so cool this
March Zendaya's first live performance
in seven years thank you all for
welcoming be back on that stage
um with open arms it's been a very long
time so I appreciate it thank you to lab
for inviting me and making all this
happen so last minute
it's been a decade since the star
released her self-titled album
[Music]
foreign
busy ever since with a very successful
acting career which includes her
emmy-winning role on Euphoria I don't
know I think I've been through a lot I
don't know what to do with it I'm
definitely proud of of the work we've
all done and I'm and I'm proud of
um
you know
um how far all these characters have
come you know there's a lot of emotions
that are attached to this I think
because this this show unlike anything
else is so personal
live with it for such a long time I mean
it's not like a movie
um where you kind of live with a
character for a brief portion of their
life and then you let go of them you
know we're with these characters for a
long ass time
we feel very emotionally invested in in
them and in the project in general I
think that's not just for us but that's
we have an entire crew of people who
dedicate every single day to uh to
making uh hopefully a beautiful piece of
art that resonates with people as for
what's next for Zendaya she's returning
alongside Timothy chalamet for Dune part
two I was excited to do it with with
this guy the two were in Vegas at
cinemacon Tuesday dishing on the sequel
which brings their characters Paul and
Johnny's relationship to the Forefront
and the world's getting a first look
with this photo
fans can catch the duo reunite on screen
when the highly anticipated sequel hits
theaters November 3rd
[Music]
foreign